President Biden set to give a prime time
address calling on Congress to pass new
gun control laws Biden will demand
action after the school's shooting in
Uvalde Texas that killed 19 students and
two teachers and after the tragedy in
Tulsa Oklahoma where a gunman killed
four people at a medical office the
president expected to twist the arm of
Congress even though he has been AWOL
during the current Senate negotiations
and is headed to the beach in Delaware
tonight the White House getting grilled
on how the president plans to press
ahead
if the president thinks that Congress
must act immediately to end this
epidemic of gun violence is he going to
bring any of the key players from
Capitol Hill to the beach with him
tonight
oh okay
um uh so I don't have a big part of
candidate Biden's whole thing that he
knows how to get things done he does he
does I mean he's he's beaten the gun
lobby before
meanwhile fireworks on Capitol Hill as
house Democrats clashed with Republicans
on new gun legislation being pushed by
the left
there's something gun crazed about our
country that we need to deal with you
are not going to bully your way into
stripping Americans of fundamental
rights if the Supreme Court objects we
will expand it and we will not rest
until we have taken weapons of war out
of circulation they want to change the
country in so many dramatic ways the in
Texas is filled with good guys with guns
but that couldn't save the lives of
those 19 children and two teachers so
this gun would be banned I hope that
that is not loaded
I'm at my house I can do whatever I want
to my Republican colleagues I ask
who are you here for
are you here for our kids or are you
here for the killers
that was a low blow as if Republicans
who believe in the Second Amendment
Jesse uh side with the killers of
children that's when it gets ridiculous
yeah he's a nasty guy I just don't care
what he says Biden has three things you
need to address tonight there's three
components there's school shootings
there are mass shootings and then there
are these Inner City Gun homicides if he
just goes in and only addresses
AR-15s the whole country is going to
dismiss that we are because this is a
larger issue and if you look at it
statistically most of the homicides are
handgun homicides by drum gangs in the
Inner City
he needs to say that and he needs to
take a holistic approach Greg likes to
talk about variables you can even
address all three of these components if
he likes to do the root cause thing I
know how much they love root causes you
go into mental health you go into broken
families you go to the toxic internet
culture red flags there's a lot of
things you can put out on the table and
we expect the president United States to
do that he needs to come with concrete
proposals tonight that can actually get
Traction in the Senate because right now
the Senate's cut him out of the
negotiation if he comes in and just
poison pills this thing and says
Republicans want everyone to die I'm
going to take your guns no right now
their main action in the Senate is
Lindsey Graham and corn and two deputies
of the minority leader Mitch McConnell
and it's basically red flag laws if they
can get action on red flag laws and get
momentum on hardening schools take the
win Mr President don't just kill it
because you're really so dug in on the
left that you have to go take our guns
take the win on that little issue and
the American people will actually say
you know what you did something everyone
says do something do something that
would be something don't you think
Jessica that it really is kind of
amazing that as as Greg has been saying
for weeks now the president has like a
one faceted approach we've got to take
the guns you have a baby now I would
assume that you would want schools
hardened you would want to know about
you know you'd want red flag laws to be
in place so that when someone shows all
of the signs that when we look back we
see all the crumbs that kind of led up
to this that there's got to be more than
just let's get rid of basically the
Second Amendment it has to be a
multi-variable approach for sure but in
terms of hardening schools some of the
things that I've heard that go into
hardening schools like teachers being
armed no I don't want that and I want
the very best for my child but but
that's about teachers being armed but
that's a big part of what people have
been talking about let's say we take
that out but do you believe in hardening
a school I believe in increased security
and so does Senator Chris Murphy from
Connecticut who has an op-ed up on
foxnews.com that everyone should check
out about the progress that he's making
in bipartisan talks and Chris Murphy
puts out there that the Democrats are
open to increase mental health
Provisions anything in red flag laws
increase security as well as expanding
background checks not even the full
monty of what they've wanted but the
tiniest incremental move towards making
Society safer and that's what everyone
that we've been talking about all week
at this table and that's what Chris
Murphy is putting out there and you know
that if there's someone the guy who
represents those Sandy Hook families is
putting it out there that that's
something that Democrats are open to and
I think that's a very good sign but no
teachers with guns that is not their job
okay all right but but the point is
there is a chance to negotiate Katie we
have a president who's on his way to the
beach yesterday he's talking about a
handguns I'll preface this conversation
by saying I do some social media work
with full courts and firearms in my
personal capacity on my social media
pages that being said the press
secretary was asked today why the
president is giving this address tonight
from the White House in prime time she
said it was because he wants his voice
to be out there on this issue which says
to me he's not going to offer much new
so let me talk about what I think he's
going to say tonight and to put some
facts on the table before he says these
things he's going to call for an assault
weapons ban without defend without
defining what an assault weapon is uh if
we're going to talk about semi-automatic
rifles that's something we can talk
about but the facts are according to the
National Institute of Justice which is a
Department of Justice Outlet 77 percent
mass shootings are committed with
handguns so if we're going to talk about
things that actually work we need to
talk about you know not just politicians
saying that we need to do something for
the sake of doing it which is very
dishonest I think the facts really
matter the president has also talked
about how you weren't allowed to own a
cannon or certain types of firearms
while when when the second amendment was
ratified yeah that is also not true and
so when it comes to you know issues of
actually getting things done there are
certain things that the federal
government just cannot do and you know
when it comes to accusing Republicans of
being pro-kid killer it's a non-starter
completely when the president doesn't
know the difference between a nine
millimeter handgun round and what the
definition of an assault rifle is that's
also a problem also there's a big
difference between what the media has
been saying what people in Washington DC
are saying with the rest of the country
thinks you got poll came out just this
week showing that actually most people
do think that teachers should be armed
the administrators should be armed this
is not a foreign concept this is half
happening in places like Utah and Texas
in Arizona this has been done no one's
being forced to do it but it is a
concept that a lot of Americans have
embraced as a solution at their local
level in their school districts so it's
a complicated issue the left tends to
throw a label on everything and act like
there's a one-size-fits-all policy I
think the mental health aspect of it is
important but then we get into issues
about veterans not seeking mental health
care because they may not be able to
exercise their Second Amendment right so
it's a compliment complicated issue that
the president apparently is going out
tonight to talk about because he wants
to make his voice heard as right before
he goes to the beach for the weekend
which says the urgency is not that bad
you know Greg it's kind of interesting
in Israel uh you know you don't hear a
lot about school shootings there and I
understand that they've hardened the
schools they have one entrance you go
through one interest all the teachers
are armed uh and they they don't
publicize it but you know there there
are people in this country who are not
even willing to discuss certain aspects
of protection that we can all agree on
there there is Common Ground isn't there
I think so but you can't find common
ground with people you don't trust and
and both sides kind of don't trust each
other I think there's a fairly good
reason why people who are strong in the
Second Amendment don't trust the other
side because the other side's wrong on
every variable when like you said
you know Biden's been around a long time
and the guy is so ignorant and insulting
when it comes to talking about guns you
cannot take them seriously the reason
why he sticks to one variable is that's
the only one he can handle I don't know
what kind of Biden you're going to get
tonight because I don't know what's left
of him to be honest right he said
Somebody's pulling his strings if I were
a mass killer I'd go to a gun-free zone
that's the first thing I would do right
because the amount of death is mitigated
by the second gun arriving that's the
science right so to to your uh statistic
it's true most Americans favor their
teachers having guns I favor it I don't
know why we would think that teachers
can't handle it unless they're on Tick
Tock if the teachers are on Tick Tock
they get no guns no the red flat that is
the red flag a teacher on on Tick Tock
talking about gender no gun for you but
uh I do think that like rather than
focus on the end result which is always
the case the single I hate saying single
variable because I sound like a broken
record but it's always the gun there are
all these steps along the way whether
it's you know school security uh with
red flags social media which is an issue
in the last 15 to 20 years this is
social media is one of the most
pernicious parts of this recipe in all
sorts of personal self-destruction
maliciousness violence but there's a
reason why I think that the left stays
away from other variables it's because
their fingerprints are all over a
culture that undermines certain
institutions that have allowed these
things to happen you know where is
family where is religion I'm not
religious but I can understand the role
that it plays in people's lives and it's
a positive role it's a positive one and
I'm agnostic and I say that religion
family mental health I know that Jessica
and I agree on Mental Health the
security of the schools that makes total
sense but you cannot address these
things if you feel in yourself that
somehow you have contributed to this
untethered alienation that we see right
now and I think that's why the left
turns away from a lot of these uh these
other are possibilities but a child like
a large bill that would tackle
everything would create trust so that if
you went after a certain segment gun
like a an age you know an age minimum
for a a rifle not an assault rifle
because that doesn't exist but a rifle
and then you put in social media and
then you put in hardening the schools
and then you put in red flags that
really that allows people to trust each
other because it's more than one
variable if it's just somebody talking
about one thing all the time you can't
trust them if they got something on the
brain and then everybody goes to their
own Corners exactly hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else